in this lesson we're going to talk about
special right triangles so special right
triangles is just something that you
might see in the context of a problem on
that you revise s80 so let's just
quickly go through the basic idea behind
special right triangles you've got the
45 45 90 triangle and the 30 60 90
triangle you just want to memorize these
ratios that in the 45 45 90 the two legs
are the two sides that make up the right
angle these are congruent they're equal
to my sausage triangle but to get to the
hypotenuse you have to multiplied by the
square root of two if they give you the
hypotenuse you can then divided by the
square root of two to get back to the
leg so let's say idea gear behind the 45
45 90 now the 30 60 90 the one that's
across in the 30 degree angle that's the
short leg that's called you call that X
and then the one is it across from the
60 degree angle that's the medium length
side that's x times the square root of
three and then the hypotenuse to one
across the right angle is 2x so let's go
through some examples and see if you can
get these problems correct so for
example one that we have a 45 45 90 this
site is for what would be the side here
and then an example to is get a 30 60 90
decide is eight we're trying to solve
for these two sides and an example three
we know this side and we're trying to
solve for x and y so go ahead and pause
the video see if you can solve these
three problems and we'll go through them
together okay so the first one is a
pretty straightforward one if this is
for this is also for and defined by
hypotenuse we just have to multiplied by
the square root of two so this is 4
squared of two no problem right this one
here they're giving us the x side right
so to get to the longer leg we're going
to multiply by the square root of three
left eighth route 3 and to get to the
hypotenuse we're just going to double it
so this is going to be 16 so that one
wasn't too bad now the third one they're
giving us the x root 3 side so to get
from extra 3 back to X what we have to
do is divide by the square root of 3 so
this is actually going to be 9 divided
by the square root of three and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
rationalize by x square root of 3 over
square root of three that's nine square
root of three square root 3 Times Square
three square root of nine which is three
and then 9 and the three you can reduce
and make that three square root of three
so that's this side right here and then
to get to the hypotenuse so you to get
from x 2 to x we're doubling so x 2 so
this would just be 6 times the square
root of three so 30 60 90 45 45 90
special right triangles definitely
something helpful to know you know in
the context of some of the problems
you're going to be doing on the new
revised s80 so again we do this if you
need to otherwise i'll see you in the
next lesson